un jour je serai plus là
vous racontez moi tout seul
tu dors pas dans la maison
en compote puis je t'emmerde
même si votre papa ne souhaitait pas bon
pour serait vraiment ce serait de
baisser le prix de 25 % à 25 % ça me
semble bien
pour faire les peintures j'ai pas du
tout envie d'entendre ce qu'ils ont à
dire à propos de la maison dès qu'ils
font des critiques j'ai envie d'arracher
les yeux va la rejoindre et souris very
call the sun is great fête du feu si je
veux je suis chez moi je vous emmerde
c'est ma copine
parce que c'est le dernier week-end
combat sans soins possibles
mais lente
la fim et ont parfait amour va très bien
ces deux là n'auraient jamais dû se
séparer voilà ce qu'on pourrait se dire
en les voyant
voilà les bêtises que l'enfance